When the word texture is used in the real world it is usually used to mean the
feel of cloth or perhaps the roughness of a material. In computer graphics the
word texture refers to any pattern or image applied to a surface to change its
color, shininess or just about any other part of its appearance. In one sense
adding a texture to a surface is another form of modeling. You're specifying
the color, roughness or reflectivity of the object based on its surface
location. The most popular way to add a texture to a surface is to use images.
Any 2D image can be applied to a surface. In these lessons, we'll delve into
how these images are attached to objects. And the various ways to control their
display. Another important use for textures is to act as surrounding
environments. While it can be expensive to attempt to have objects reflect
other objects in a scene. It turns out to be extremely fast to reflect textures
representing a whole environment. There are some limiations, but surfaces can
be made to look much more realistic and visually rich by this simple addition.
Even an approximation of refraction can be done with this type of technique. In
this unit I'll provide you with the basics of how various forms of texturing
works. I'll also be taking you on a tour of some of the major effects
achievable with textures. I won't be explaining all of these in detail. The
good news is, the code for almost all the demos you'll see are part of 3JS.
This gives you the ability to easily prod and poke at these various effects,
and see what makes them tick. I strongly encourage you to do so. I did this
myself in creating some of these lessons, and it was a lot of fun.